hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Doctor Who episode 11 video if you
didn't know this was the first part of a
two-part finale so there is one more
episode next week so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet rule number one of dying don't rule
number two slow down we'll have to take
a poll for best mine palace between
Sherlock and Doctor Who of course the
TARDIS is going to be the doctor's my
palace
but actually before we get started I
should say new round of the giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video so super high concept
episode that answered a bunch of
questions I think the thing I was most
happy about you know in addition to the
big twist or that it actually gave us
some really big answers especially the
hybrid and the confession dial those are
really two of the three big reveals in
the episode there were like three big
reveals the last one being what was on
the other side of the confession dial so
tie five WTF number five the doctor
materializes in a mysterious tower that
reconfigures itself the way they play
the episode you think he's been trapped
there by someone else but then you
gradually learned that it's a closed
energy loop and it's a trap of his own
design I'm trapped in a puzzle box with
no way out or I could be in hell
it must be Christmas all I could think
about was River Song when he said that
although I knew she wasn't gonna be in
this episode the set design of the
castle was amazing the way they make it
feel so grand and claustrophobic at the
same time it's the perfect episode for
the doctor being by himself
like a one-person episode despite the
fact that we have this creature that I
guess I'll just call the veil like we
have the doctor in the veil eventually
we find out that it really is the doctor
by himself the veil is just a device of
the confession dial sidebar if the
confession dial is the last will and
testament of every time Lord does that
mean the confession doubt being a
backdoor to Gallifrey is something that
every time Lord has access to or is this
confession Dalek just unique to the
doctor somebody get Moffat on the phone
it reminds me a lot of the episode
listen from series 8 where we get to see
the doctor by himself
working out problems on the chalkboard
like what does the doctor do when he's
by himself well he talks to himself a
lot but the twist in an anima number 4
WTF is that Clara speaks to him inside
the TARDIS mind palace so Clara did come
back but she is mine palace Clark she's
completely a creation of his mind I
think it's a really fitting way to
memorialize her
that this episode itself was kind of a
memorial to Clara just because the
doctor thinks about her so much the hard
part isn't the dying it's every day
thereafter that they stay dead who else
thought it was a little mysterious that
his handwriting was so perfect on that
blackboard that's the minute I was like
okay this is probably Clara's
handwriting they made the reveal later
on and she ends up speaking eventually
and then touching his face but it's all
in his mind and deeper in the episode
they do this weird thing where the
blackboard is actually inside the castle
so it's really hard to tell whether the
doctors reimagining himself running
through the castle or if the blackboard
itself is inside the castle it's such a
high concept episode it's so much fun
and as the doctor slowly starts to
figure out the mechanism of the castle
it starts to become this big meta
commentary on Doctor Who as a series in
general those are my favorite type of
Doctor Who references when it starts
referencing itself but it also becomes
this meta commentary for the series as a
whole like how long can I keep doing
this the doctor examining Doctor Who
even though mine palace Clara is really
the doctor talking to himself it becomes
this big reaffirmation like yes you must
go on can I lose this once no no you
can't speaking of mind Palace cut twos
let me know which cut was your favorite
like when he jumped out the window but
the first time he digs that grave in the
Vale almost grabs him and it just slam
cuts to the mind Palace TARDIS well that
was a close one on my number three WTF
the Doctor discovers that the only way
to stop the Vale is to make confessions
which makes sense now that we know that
the Vale was a device of the confession
dial just the confessions in general
were amazing especially early on before
he starts talking about the hybrid fine
I didn't leave Gallifrey because I was
bored I was afraid that's really the
point where the episode starts to get
really scary it's not so much like him
realizing that the Clara painting is
seven thousand years old it's once he
starts to put the pieces together of the
closed energy loop the stars are all in
the wrong place how long have I been
here so out of my number two WTF the
doctor realizes that it's a closed
energy loop and that he's the only one
in the prison and he's been there for
forever all the skulls belong to him
that's the moment when the episode stops
being comedy horror just starts being
pure horror the doctor was that
mysterious figure at the beginning of
the episode that plugged himself into
the transport device to pull another
copy out he has that big call-to-action
on
not gonna tell you anything more about
the hybrid and starts punching away at
that diamond wall he actually says it's
like four hundred times harder than
diamond they just want you to know that
it's supposed to be impossible for
anyone to break through like he can't
just smash it with anything so he just
starts beating away at it with his bare
fists he suddenly recalls the Brothers
Grimm lovely fellows in the story about
the emperor how many seconds in eternity
and we get that amazing montage of the
doctor just going through the same
events over and over and over with this
great soundtrack by Murray gold probably
the best soundtrack from any episode
this series you could actually just
listen to the music but after two
billion years or so he finally beats his
way through the wall of time so to speak
it seems like a physical thing but so
much to the episode is high concept and
mental it becomes this metaphor of him
beating his way through time like I'm
never gonna stop it's as big
reaffirmation for Doctor Who is a series
like yeah how many times can we do this
well we can keep doing this for forever
what's two billion years to a Time Lord
I feel like that's the big wink to the
fandom like we are never going to quit
there will always be some form of Doctor
Who but he beats his way through a wall
and it forms this portal out of the
confession dial on to Gallifrey and
everyone's like oh my god everyone like
flips our so of course on to my
number one WTF the doctor calls himself
out as the hybrid you had a prophecy
before the time war that a creature
would arise a hybrid half Dalek half
Time Lord
the Daleks though would never allow that
to happen I confess I am the hybrid
destined to conquer Gallifrey and stand
in its ruins if you hadn't flipped your
desk over an excitement yet I feel like
this was the moment let me know when you
guys figured out that he was on
Gallifrey though but before the camera
turned around to reveal the city for me
it was really when he told the boy to
run to the city like when he gave him
that message tell them I'm coming and I
want my way I'll say most of me you know
throughout the episode knew he would
probably end up on Gallifrey I just
didn't know how it would happen I didn't
realize that the confession dial would
be the MacGuffin to get him there what
did you guys think about the confession
dial though how did you like that
MacGuffin like that being a backdoor to
Gallifrey there's a whole lot of
questions that they didn't answer
hopefully they'll address some of them
in the finale but I just love the
imagery of the confession dial as like a
big pocket watch like the doctor was
traveling through his pocket watch to
get back to Gallifrey two billion years
definitely the long way around but
really I think
dr. being the hybrid is more reference
to him being half human that's really
something that they addressed during the
1996 movie if you never watched the
Doctor Who movie you should check it out
at some point there's actually a quote
that Moffat gave in reference to the
doctor being half-human talking about
the 8th doctor and it says keeping in
mind that everything you know for sure
is probably wrong answer me this in
which story is it confirmed definitively
that the doctor is not human now that's
from Offutt own mouth so you can take it
however II will but that's just what I
took the imagery of the hybrid to be in
this episode here are my big questions
for you guys let me know in the comments
how did you feel about the way they
wrote this episode just the style in
general and what did you think about the
MacGuffin of the confession dial the way
they used it as a back door to Gallifrey
well I guess think about that here are
some of the Easter eggs from the episode
so one there is no TARDIS in this
episode although he thought there might
be a TARDIS behind that wall there was
no TARDIS for a giant portion of 3rd
doctor episodes when he was in exile on
earth but there's also mission to the
unknown the Sontaran experiment genesis
of the Daleks and midnight those are
other really big episodes where there
was no TARDIS of course the doctor gets
back on Gallifrey soil by the end of the
episode the first time he physically
travelled back to Gallifrey was a second
doctor episode called the war games they
asked him why he ran away
and he said well I was bored so Capaldi
saying and this episode confessing I
wasn't bored I was scared is a big
reference to that second doctor episode
but we didn't actually learn the name of
the planet was Gallifrey till a much
much later episode called the time
warrior and it's not really an easter
egg but just you know fun
behind-the-scenes fact about making the
episode the actor that played the veil
is the same actor that played colony
sarff back during Magician's apprentice
and which is familiar depending on what
happens in the actual finale we could
see some references to the fourth doctor
because Tom Baker actually did travel
back to Gallifrey without a companion so
there have been Doctor Who episodes with
him back on Gallifrey by himself but I
just love the tease at the end of the
episode as if he's going to conquer
Gallifrey and stand on its ruins so all
in all great episode I really I really
hope the last episode episode 12 really
sticks the landing we do have the
Christmas special but that's really
gonna be its own thing like its own
River Song story the other big thing you
need to keep in the back of your mind is
who is going to be the new companion
Moffat has probably already found them
but we might not see them till
ten episode one so my next video is
going to be episode 12 next week then
I'll start doing some Christmas special
videos I know a lot of you been asking
for some Sherlock Christmas special
videos I'll start doing that too
especially once we get into December
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winners Oh Supergirl you win a $20
Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info just in
case you guys haven't seen there's been
a whole bunch of big trailers to drop in
the last couple of days you can click
here for the Captain America civil war
trailer and you can click here for my
Doctor Who series 9 playlist thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys later
tonight long way around I promise